you must have heard the term digital
marketing online marketing and have
always been curious about how
individuals and businesses use it to
increase brand awareness
the growth of digital marketing is fast
and it will continue to grow in the
coming years don't worry if you have no
idea what digital marketing is this
video will explain everything you need
to know
hey everyone i am tushar badiwal welcome
to simply learns youtube channel in this
video we will understand digital
marketing from scratch but before we
begin if you enjoy watching tech related
content consider subscribing to our
youtube channel and hitting that bell
icon to stay tuned
so without any further delay let's get
started with the agenda for today's
session first we will look at what
digital marketing is next we will
understand the different components of
digital marketing moving forward we will
understand the difference between
traditional and digital marketing and
why it is preferable to go digital after
that we will dive into the challenges
for digital marketers in 2022
next we will look at the top skills
required to become a digital marketer
after that we will discuss the average
salary of a digital marketing manager
and finally we will wind up the session
by discussing the future of digital
marketing hopefully now you have a
better idea of what we have in store for
you
now let's see what digital marketing is
in simple words digital marketing is the
promotion of a product or a brand
through one or more forms of electronic
media such as internet mobile phones
google search engine marketing etc it's
a way to reach client on time and retain
them with interactive marketing using
digital technologies also it is the most
accessible easy to use and contemporary
method of promotion which is also known
as online marketing
so now we have a clear understanding of
what digital marketing is we also need
to acknowledge that it has several
components and understanding each is
essential so let's jump into the
different components of digital
marketing
seo seo stands for search engine
optimization seo is the act of taking
steps to help a website or a piece of
content get higher ranking on google
moreover seo includes organic rankings
which means you do not have to pay to
appear there
up next we have ppc ppc stands for
pay-per-click it includes paid
advertisements and promoted search
engine results
it does the same thing as seo but the
key difference is that it's inorganic so
you have to pay to be in that space the
next component is social media marketing
social media marketing is a form of
internet marketing that uses social
media apps as a marketing tool brands
can communicate with their audience
using social media platforms whether
they are building a brand increasing
sales driving traffic to our website or
building followers to share and engage
with the content
next we have content marketing content
marketing aims to increase brand
awareness by telling stories and sharing
information ultimately the goal is to
encourage leaders to become customers by
signing up for an email list asking for
more information or making a purchase
email marketing involves sending
promotional messages to many people at
once in most cases it's used to generate
lead for sales but it can also include
advertising
the next component that we will be
discussing is affiliate marketing
affiliate marketing is a component of
marketing in which one person promotes
another company's or person's product a
person who promotes a product or service
is called an affiliate and the affiliate
also gets a certain amount of commission
up next we have mobile marketing with
this type of digital marketing you will
reach your target audience on the
smartphones mobile marketing reaches
people through text messages social
media websites emails and mobile
applications
now we are on to our last component
which is influencer marketing
influencer marketing involves promoting
your product through mentions and
endorsement from influencers
individuals who have a dedicated
following on social media are seen as
industry experts
now let's have a look at the business
models in digital marketing
b2b which means business to business
b2b refers to business transaction
between two companies in the world of
b2b digital marketing is a crucial
element
through a digital market campaign we can
reach another company's decision maker
one of the best example is linkedin
advertising which many b2b companies use
to target their potential customers
next we have b2c which is business to
consumer
b2c refers to business transactions
between business to consumer b2c digital
marketing allows you to reach out
directly to your potential customers
using digital channels
as we know millions of people are using
internet and are active on digital
channels for example using facebook ads
and google ads you can directly target
consumers by their age group interest
location etc
and the final one is c2c which is
consumer to consumer
c2c refers to a business transaction
between consumers nowadays consumers are
using social media platforms and
intermediaries to market their products
and services as a result they can reach
a wider audience for example olx serves
as an intermediary by allowing
individuals to list their products and
services for sale and other individual
can purchase them
now let's look into digital marketing
versus traditional marketing
several new and old businesses are
harnessing digital marketing and
rethinking their marketing funnels in
the age of digital marketing a digital
revolution has reshaped how we live
interact and conduct businesses
traditional marketing seems to be losing
its relevance in today's era of
technology knowing which marketing
method will work best for your business
is essential
traditional marketing methods such as
printing material radio and television
are quickly becoming outdated they are
too expensive ineffective and time
consuming however digital marketing is
the future of advertising now let's talk
about a few reasons why digital
marketing is a better choice than
traditional marketing
firstly there is a global reach a
website that allows you to find a new
market and trade globally for only a
small investment
lower cost a properly planned and well
targeted digital marketing campaign can
reach the right customers at a much
lower cost than traditional marketing
methods
the next benefit is analytics several
tools are available to analyze and
report on marketing data collected
through digital channels and the data is
precious to any business
now we are on to our last benefit which
is retargeting suppose we have a website
that sells shoes and hundred people
visit our website but only two purchase
the item
with the help of digital marketing we
can still target those 98 visitors and
display our ads to them
people used to rely on traditional
marketing before digital marketing
traditional marketing is nothing new as
we have all seen and heard of it at some
point
it is an effective way to reach a
particular audience via offline methods
such as magazines newspaper billboards
etc traditional marketing has its
challenges such as time consuming a
limited number of customers served in
one go and a high cost similarly digital
marketing has its own challenges
now let's look into the challenges in
digital marketing learning about your
customers the internet has lot of users
with lot of different interest which
makes identifying the right sort of
audience for your product and service
challenging at times the next challenge
is the generation of qualified leads in
a competitive market the digital
revolution has resulted in businesses
using digital marketing but sometimes it
becomes challenging to compete against
your competitors
next is compliance with privacy and data
sharing regulations
most people have their own website which
can attract visitors from anywhere in
the world
ensure that you are compliant with any
laws that apply to your target audience
up next we have developing an
omni-channel marketing strategy
multi-device and multi-platform use are
increasing among customers the days of
relying solely on a single strategy like
email or facebook are over
your strategy must be based on multiple
platforms
staying up to date with google's
algorithm the digital empire of google
continues to grow to compete you need to
stay up to date with the latest features
rules and algorithms released by this
giant search engine
now we are on to our last challenge
developing a mobile first strategy
the number of people browsing and
shopping from smartphones and tablets
has increased if somebody wants to
capture a share of ever spending mobile
market
they must ensure that their website is
mobile friendly
now that we have a better sense of
challenges faced in digital marketing
it's essential to be equipped with the
right skills to handle them
now let's look at what top skills a
digital marketer needs it is crucial for
anyone planning a career in digital
marketing to understand what are the top
skills required it takes a wide range of
soft and hard skills for digital
marketers to succeed as a digital
marketer you will need a different set
of skills depending on where you work
and what you do data analysis data
analytics uses functional procedures and
modern software programs to gather and
analyze information from various online
interaction with your target market
content creation creating content that
appeals to a brand's target audience is
crucial for digital marketing
seo and sem it is important to utilize
relevant and specific keywords as
google's algorithm constantly updates
both seo and sem help you reach your
target audience and narrow down your
customer base
basic designing skill digital marketers
should be familiar with software such as
adobe creative suit
photoshop after effect illustrator and
design etc and canva as these would
enhance their ability to create visual
content
social media businesses use social media
platforms to target their content to
specific audience and get accurate data
for this reason a digital marketer needs
to be very familiar with social media
platforms
communication skill an influential
digital marketer should look at things
from a different perspective
convey information in an easy to
understand manner and figure out what
audience find entertaining and valuable
let's look at an example to understand
digital marketing better
raj owns a bakery shop in bangalore but
he does not know how to market it he
called his best friend rahul and he
suggested trying out digital marketing
here are few examples raj can try
create a business plan for weekly
develop a business website with seo and
include online ordering
add a blog post for effective content
marketing
use social media effectively
cat is google my business listing and
optimize it for seo market his shops
through facebook and google
ads hopefully now you have a better
understanding of the top skills which is
required to become a digital marketer
if you are interested in learning these
skills and are looking for a resource to
learn digital marketing from scratch
then simplylearn has postgraduate
program in digital marketing it is the
world's number one digital marketing
course by marketing land and search
engine journal program duration is 6
months 5 to 10 hours per week is
required for the program and the best
part is you will get job assistance from
our end and when it comes to content
then it is created by the industry
experts here are the key features of our
program you will get pgp and digital
marketing certificate and purdue
university alumni membership party
university faculty master class free
facebook blueprint voucher worth 99
harvard business case study of yahoo
echo tripadvisor etc industry projects
and course and projects you can get
noticed by top hiring companies which
simply learns job assist
now we have reached the most exciting
and essential part of the video average
salary of a digital marketing manager in
the digital marketing industry there is
a huge demand for digital marketing
managers and their salaries reflect that
several factors determine the income a
person can expect including experience
the size of your company your location
and your industry
digital advertising has proven to be
more convenient and effective than
traditional advertising since most of
your audience is online as a result
digital marketing is growing and
becoming more popular a digital
marketing manager plays a significant
role in drawing revenue into the
business and due to their highly
result-driven nature their salaries are
high
a digital marketing manager earns
approximately 6 lakh 72 000 per year in
india and in the u.s he or she can earn
roughly 75 000 dollars per year
lastly let's discuss the future of
digital marketing grandview research
reports that the global digital
marketing software market size was usd
56.52 billion in 2021 and is expected to
grow at a compound annual growth rate
cagr of 19.1 percent from 2022 to
2030. have looked into the new digital
marketing trends at some point if you
are aspiring or experienced digital
marketer the best way to succeed in
digital marketing is to keep up with
current trends in the field now we will
look at the two trending technologies
that use digital marketing and are on
the rise
blockchain the data from digital
advertising campaign can sometimes be
inaccurate so improvement can be
difficult
monitoring marketing campaigns in real
time is achievable with blockchain for
obtaining trustworthy metrics top brands
such as unilever are applying blockchain
for improving digital advertising
efficiency successfully
augmented and virtual reality stock bugs
nivia and volkswagen all launched
successfully ar and vr campaigns to
better connect their brands and products
to their customer it is undeniable that
these two technologies are booming and
expected to grow massively in the next
few years the use of digital marketing
in these technologies makes us aware the
bright future of digital marketing
here's what you have learned so far
initially we discussed what digital
marketing is then the components of
digital marketing next we discussed
digital marketing business models after
that we discussed digital marketing
versus traditional marketing and then
the challenges of digital marketing
after that we discussed the top skills
required to become a digital marketer
next we discuss the salary part and
finally we discussed the future of
digital marketing
so with this we have come to the end of
this session on digital marketing i hope
the session was informative and exciting
in case you have questions about any of
the topics covered in the session or if
you need
the resources used in this session then
please feel free to let us know in the
comment section below and our team of
experts will be more than happy to
resolve all your queries at the earliest
until next time this is tushar from
simply learns team signing off thank you
stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here